good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials I know you
probably can't tell but I'm really
excited to be here but I got Botox so I
can no longer raise my eyebrows
it's so exciting how do you feel that I
my my teeth in my sleep and it causes my
eyebrows to turn so now that I'm a
little sore from the Botox I feel like a
little like a little pain every time I
cross my eyebrows I'm like oh this is
why I have wrinkles because I literally
can't talk move speak or nothing do my
makeup without at least raising or
crossing my eyebrows for me it's a
little pain when I do my makeup right
now but it's worth every minute of it
plus the past few nights I've been
getting like headaches before I go to
sleep and last night I did not because
Botox helps with migraines so I had
actually got a migraine not a migraine
there's a difference between a migraine
and a headache I had a headache last
night just because I was sore and like
it was I wasn't sure if it was like it
was definitely related but and now I
forgot that there additional side effect
of Botox is that it helps with migraine
so I'm even more excited to try it out
and honestly me and Jackie went together
and like right before I sat down I
watched you do it which was a big
mistake but you were in a rush so you
had to go first but in an ideal world I
would have went first because I was so
up close seeing like your skin you know
me seeing you doing it it's like weird
even the pictures that you took of some
of them it's like you see the needle in
it's weird but I was so nervous like you
know the feeling right before you're
gonna think we're like your legs feel
like cold and cold like I feel hungry
like I really thought I was gonna faint
I was so nervous I don't know why I
didn't even hurt it hurts a little but
it really doesn't wow that's really big
coming from you that no I know because I
have like the absolute lowest tolerance
for pain and I was mentally you have the
lowest tolerance for pain no physically
- I don't know because technically
redheads scientifically had the lowest
tolerance for pain
okay like generally you could be a
redhead with a high tolerance like I
don't think so I just think I'm a tough
chick I'm a cub I'm a checkerboard chick
I need to watch hairspray yeah you do
with Amanda Bynes I want to watch Ricki
Lake Amanda Bynes and then hairspray
live just to see how how bad to fail
that was and also a hairspray was on
Broadway I'm surprised it didn't have
like a longer run we saw yeah yeah well
I feel like all shows you know they come
and go Lion King doesn't wicked doesn't
that's true I want to see wicked that's
did it our stories are gonna grande for
kid no but one of our stories is Ariana
Grande so you can parlay that is Frankie
can't can't
no no separately not freaky I can't wait
for that alright I got a wicked thing I
can't find gravity it's like okay also
cuz I'm going to Cleveland tomorrow and
Cleveland Ohio Ohio is where they
Shockley so like I'm just like I'm
getting into my glee mode and the
episode of Glee where Kurt wants to sing
defying gravity even that was obviously
made for Rachel but it has a high F so
they both audition for it and obviously
Kurt misses the hi Evan pretends like he
missed on purpose so he took of it but
like even though we know he he really
wanted it and it's like really it
should've gone to Mercedes Oh completely
she would by the way of the whole show
like she got shafted she was like you
guys bring me in at the end of every
song she like belt out one note and I'm
better than all of you but I couldn't
agree more
it's like in the beginning she totally
got shafted and they were totally
sleeping on her and then towards the end
they realized they were sleeping on her
so they like propped her up but not with
the right song and then she became a
diva and felt entitled to all the solos
we're like some songs are made for
Mercedes but some songs are not are made
for Rachel like some songs aren't strong
enough songs that she could feel like
she over sings them right it's like I'm
drea Bocelli singing on perfect with
that cheering right voice it's too
professional to be singing a song made
by a tenure there's not enough song
there right so like I completely agree
with that I don't know how I go so
defying gravity like I can't went and
makeup by Mario was posting videos
without sound because he was there doing
her makeup and I'm like Mario he was
doing
Ariana's makeup and I'm like you have to
send me the videos like I need to see
like that song something has changed
within me something is not the same too
late for second-guessing too late to go
back to sleep it's time to trust my
instincts close my eyes and leave it's
time to it's hard to sing like without
raising my eyebrows oh oh my god he's
gonna change your voice again gravity
like that song gets me every time and
like there are only a few people in the
world who can sing it Lea Michele idina
menzel
and Ariana Grande like I'm so excited
what's it for I don't even know what the
wicked special is I think it's like 10
years of wicked or something this you do
wicked NBC live they should but like who
could
play the wizard who could play Adina oh
there's some good alpha talents out
there Lea Michele what I'll do it she
could be great she would be great she
wouldn't be amazing and then we kind of
dove Cameron as Glinda yes is that the
Good Witch yeah and then who would be
the wizard well he's a farce
who else is the character in there the
man that they fight over dancing through
life dancing through life that used to
make a song from the soundtrack by the
way if you love define grab I guess if
you don't like SoulCycle doesn't matter
but like I musical Mondays he usually
plays define guys every week and it is
insane yeah
me nah no western sky by Ben's doing
someone told me lately everyone deserves
a chance to fly and if I'm flying solo
Henley some fly game free for those who
ground me take a message back from me
tell them how I am defying one of TB G's
friends okay first of all I love hanging
out with TV Jake just because like we're
kindred spirits and like we were meant
for each other and like Abby should be
married so I can move into his apartment
but he and his like he's like a really
close group of friends that they've been
friends for like seven years and every
time I'm hanging out with them like a
variety of them are there and he has one
friend who works on Broadway and it's
like obsessed with Broadway and it's
just Broadway Broadway Broadway and
every time I get together and we're like
hanging out and drinking we play show
tunes I'm like he's like us like he is
the same interest I think we just
literally should come to camp toast
because that's what I'm toast
oh my god by the way totally and he
works for like the Broadway like sad
like what he's saying Gaston acam toasts
like I actually thought I was gonna have
a heart and I never had that feeling
again until I think you can't stop they
need to make later right oh my god yeah
no I had so many heart attacks by the
way at camp shows no furry like oh so I
just found out that a wedding I'm I'm
assuming I'm gonna be invited to is um
Memorial Day weekend so I guess I can't
go is it an important wedding um it's
gonna be the fun destination wedding and
it's been spreadin so I'm fine
okay Ben Kim yeah Ben time makes baby up
anyway but by the way Ben is couple of
saying the toast tomorrow and you have
to ask him about his first experience
doing SoulCycle which is right now he's
never been why is he there so Ben's
friend Erik is like a health nut he's he
owns like Holly restaurant
he's health health health works out like
we're from Eric Oh totally thank you
ever been I saw him for Ben has a friend
Eric - Ben stole him for me it's my
friend Eric thank you and he's always
inviting him to SoulCycle because Eric's
best friend is at Caen oh so he's like
the SoulCycle like guy like everyone
wants to his class his classes literally
sell out before even noon on Mondays and
I just his class once and it was really
hard and Nina Agdal was like front-row
Center and that and she was like dating
leo at the time and it's like who wants
to Seoul next to that his girlfriend
yeah but he has like a cult following
and he always is like Tibet you should
come to a class and Ben's like yeah so
Ben action and went to akan this morning
he's there now oh my god did you tell
snitch
no snitch our intern literally texted me
today she's only here two days a week
and out because of school she do you
guys need me today I guess not but this
9/3 a [ __ ] no it's really cool how its
nature have an internship and then she
became the boss like she's really risen
the corporate reign no honestly like you
could learn a lot from her
they are your shoes are you shoes I'm
Jimmy my shoes are M Jimmy I got the
same pair that's so funny because we're
able to get we picked out shoes from M
Jimmy which is like a new Italian luxury
that's the way I literally chose the
same pair of the whole website because
we're kindred spirits you should move in
with me those are much more my style
than yours well I just needed like a
pair of new white sneakers like fresh
kicks honestly because if homeboy rolls
up and those like you know he didn't
know he can make it get it um and so I
picked these ones and they're like
actually made from good leather I have
it which is new for me yeah
wait there's and they weren't expensive
no they're not like and they're just
online free shipping free returns at M
Jimmy oh my god free returns I literally
have three returns sitting on my couch
right now that I just I don't know
printer so how can I just I I can't even
with not free returns if it's not for
your turns I'll just wear the wrong size
know if it's not free returns like it
looks like it's staying in my closet
right looks like I'm giving it to a
sister they're cute they're really cute
and they're really comfortable and I
like your purple sock it's a pop of
color it's a pop of color and my black
and white motif and they're affordable
yeah which is just what more could a
girl want what more could it go on and
if you want to go see for yourself how
amazing these shoes are at em Jimmy calm
slash toast for $50 off your first pair
that's a lot I know that's letter M GE m
Icom slash toasts for $50 off your first
pair M Jimmy calm slash toast em Jimmy
Italian luxury made the old way sold the
new way no they're all about you and I
can't believe we chose the same pair cuz
they've like a million pairs of like
loafers that I really didn't pick any
pair on the site I mean picked the same
pair but I really liked I I find that
every time I buy a white pair of
sneakers from like a shitty website or
something like I I can wear them out
twice and then they're brown brown yeah
they're not made well I feel like these
have longevity like there's just texture
in them yeah I like them a lot and you
probably can't tell because I'm not
moving my eyebrows but I'm very excited
about the shoes if you didn't see oh
wait I feel like I would I may be too
clean unlike my shoes my leggings are
made out of garbage and every time I
wear this pair of leggings they split
down the middle did you split already I
don't know let me splash me okay
when I wore these wet leggings last it
was when we had Tyler Henry the medium
on and and you never know but my
leggings were split down the middle you
never know because that enter view never
made it to air because we got fired the
next day but that was a good interview
and he was really nice and really
sweating yeah he was really nice but he
didn't read us and it's like Theresa
Caputo went on daily pop and read like
was like talking she's like Morgan your
grandma's he I'm a nod right and she had
met with Justin in a hotel a few days
before and they filmed it and she gave
him like a full reading well I would be
nervous to get a reading like online I
mean I'm sorry live because I she'd be
like okay your father's coming in he's
mildly disappointed like I would need to
pre-record to make sure no sex just
because he was like a big fan of her
work but she was like just doing her
interview and she was like Morgan did
you lose a paternal grandmother we
Jackie we have to get Theresa you know
me let me have been on her waitlist like
I know and it was a two-year waitlist
five years ago we never got a call so it
seems like the only way to get her is to
book her on your show right a bad way
except that I did run and turn the Delta
Sky Lounge and she couldn't have in
ruder I take the fame really went to her
head Wow I mean Scott tells the skyline
just like it's a tense situation no one
thinks I'm one right no not Delta
skyline specifically but just traveling
like if you come up to me while I'm
traveling it's like I'm just so ashamed
about the way that I look and I'm not
gonna be nice because I don't want you
to look at me no I mean just mean like
it was me it was weird I'm sorry like
she was hurt and now that I said that
she won't come on the show I have like a
thread in my eye I think you got it no I
guess I'll just go blind that's fine
that's fine like Carlos in desparate
okay
are you ready for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you make up
take a bite out of your morning toast of
course I'm always ready maybe you're not
ready no I'm not actually because here
take your eyelashes go overload your
eyelid over the bottom two let's count
to ten one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten now I just have a tear oh
are you sad cuz he missed the oh I do
miss the oh he was such a good boy
yesterday except oh my god me and Jackie
went to get our eyebrows done and then
we went chopping up her dress for like
things we can't afford we literally
picked out a Judith Leiber clutch I was
five thousand nine hundred ninety five
dollars I'm like okay well if we split
it and then we put a half of it on the
toast and we wear it to the CME and we
also had our mom's credit card we're
like okay we put half on this car you
were like try to slip on a million cards
we didn't get Steve when he has to buy a
suit for Miranda's cash this sad
checkbook I can't oh wait so I was so
worried about Theo like peeing in this
fancy store and because like he can
either be like an angel or the devil and
I was so worried about him and not
worried about myself that I stepped on
his foot
and he [ __ ] helped so loud in the
store the whole store went silent and
looked at us and I was mortified and it
was my fault like I was so worried about
my dog embarrassing me I don't even
think about me embarrassing me you
remember seeing my dog on behalf of here
I felt so bad and you know sometimes you
step on it so it's like a light I
literally like my whole body weight and
my new big ass Fila sneakers like
kerplunk on him he's dead oh my god well
I gave him a little paw massage after
Theo has just been like on every day he
is a better and better boy no I mean I
was thinking that today because I don't
want to jinx it knock on one a million
times but since we moved into this
apartment he's not had an accident and
we have like new rugs coming and
everything and he hasn't but I don't
want to jinx it's like you know it's on
its way and he's excited about his new
couch s coming today I mean he might
have to break it in and you know mark
his territory
what's so annoying here's what's
annoying thank you for asking what's
annoying is that the couch comes today
and I have a full thing errands to do
because I go to Cleveland and your
bachelorette party tomorrow so like I
have to pack for all that get a manicure
pedicure wax all that stuff and we have
two events to go to tonight so I won't
even get to spend the day with my couch
I won't and Ben's gonna have his friends
over for football on Sunday and ruminate
so I won't get to see my couch until
Monday I'm sorry
or like take pictures of it and it's
coming probably when Ben's there and you
know Ben isn't gonna vacuum before it
goes down and like then I'm gonna have
to do it he's like um whatever I was
meant to do it yesterday but I was just
too lazy
just let Thea eat it by the way having
laundry in my apartment has changed my
life clean undies all the time that's
what it is it used to be like fundies
and people it's like there's an
association where it's like if you don't
do your own laundry you're like spoiled
yeah but it's like in the city if you
don't if you have a laundry machine
you're spoiled but if you don't have one
then you have to send it out you're
spoiled the only way to not be spoiled
is to go to the laundromat and do it
yourself I guess but like who has to get
out of busy city it's an idiot never so
it's just so funny because it's a - my
own laundry whereas in New York if you
do your own laundry like you're entitled
and spoiled and now I'm one of these
people because it used to be like if I
had something that I wanted to wear that
was in the laundry you like it's just
too bad
yeah like it won't be back till next
week look it was just too damn bad if
I'm done the undies I don't have to
order new ones on Amazon like I can't
wash them right Gristedes actually is
where I get my underwear so now just
like to have a constant stream of
laundry like I just my under I draw
drawers full like at all times it's
really just it's so crazy
that's how normal people live like not
in the city and like right it's an
amazing thing I do how often do you do
laundry I think I do a load every day oh
no once a week I do like many loads some
let's say need something or we're going
on a trip or like exact means certain
things like my pajamas for the shows
like I just washed them oh that's nice I
used to have to literally buy a new and
then only like $20 from Amazon but still
I would literally buy a new pair of
pajamas for every show it's so stupid
that's funny um are you ready now yes
because we weren't ready before even
though he's having already first story
Lady Gaga confirmed she's engaged to
Christian Karina as she calls him her
fiance at Beverly Hills event so we all
knew she was engaged but now she just
confirmed it so therefore it's in the
news again and it's really in the news
because she wore the one of the weirdest
Alva it's like this enormous suit um
yeah Lady Gaga work some of her own news
on Monday evening while being honored at
the women in Hollywood Awards hosted by
Elle magazine in Beverly Hills the 32
year old singer confirmed she's engaged
the stars born actress has been with
Christian Kirino for over a year now for
over a year and has been wearing a
diamond engagement ring for several
months
rumors began November that she was set
to Wed the agent as she often more time
during her speech she thanked her fiance
Christian who was in the audience and
posed with her at the event very very
sweet and also there are rumors going
around that her engagement ring could be
worth over a million dollars oh I saw
four hundred thousand well page six is
for I saw four hundred thousand and then
I saw a million well regardless the more
important thing to note is that she 100%
bought it herself because he is like an
agent and like yes he definitely makes a
lot of money but not enough for a four
hundred thousand dollar ring right but
it's honestly a beautiful ring and every
time she gets engaged her rings really
shocked me because her ring was Mark
Kinney was a heart which is like not
myself not Lady Gaga's style because
it's like more of a soft kitschy like a
sort of thing you know someone who's
like not super edgy right she's actually
and edgy people don't wear hearts no
they don't they just don't I'm pink yes
I thought it looked purple in the
picture that I saw whatever it's like a
magenta and I just think it's really
funny like the way that Christian Kirino
looks because in this picture that he
they posed together out in the event and
there's a photo of them and he has like
spiked hair like shaved sides earring
like he looks so different after being
dating Lady gaga for a year whereas like
a year ago like he was like wearing a
suit and tie to his corporate job every
day right and they wonder when his
co-workers think of him because like I
at one point in time was an agent was a
client of CAA and like I've been in the
office and looks very corporate like
like if you were dating an agent right
there's no fraternizing he'd be coming
to where he'd start coming to work like
in his pj's
I mean I one point like did want to date
my agent he's so hot but whatever it
didn't work out I didn't work out
because like we're both married and he's
like actually one of those handsome
people I but it's Hollywood
anything goes totally he had stayed
there too long honestly yes then you got
out you know totally cause like the
connection between me and Dave like it
was just it was electric it's electric
no it really was like I know that he
thinks about me all the time probably
because like of your work yeah and
because he like probably got fire I've
got in trouble for like hiring such a
controversial client
anyways her ring is 11 or 12 carats and
a natural pink diamond of this
saturation in size would be very where
rare easily costing over a million
dollars well I'm really happy for her
and Christian Kirino but I really do
feel like her and Taylor Kenny are meant
for each other a green and this is like
a fun thing she can do on the side if
they're not really gonna get married and
they're not really the people for each
other because her in Taylor Kinney
kindred spirits and they're just wasting
time until they both are their schedules
open up open up enough that they can
actually live together and like be happy
and I'm solely conflicted about Lady
gaga right now because on the one hand
like she looks like she's living her
best wife but then on the other hand
like you see things and you hear things
that would leak what do you see here
like just some blinds and like I know I
don't like she's not like like sober
okay well I I feel like some people just
exist that way and right and and it's
fine and if you find her documentary you
could tell that their conversations your
she's having where she's like [ __ ] up
yeah but like she's very lucid and it
[ __ ] out and she's an artist so like
it helps her creatively I definitely
understand that I thought you were what
you were gonna say and what I think is
that like she is definitely living her
best life her career has never been
better she's happy in a relationship but
she definitely gives me the vibe that
like she cries herself to sleep at night
yeah there's like something like ms
occur there's something missing
yeah and she does have that chronic pain
and I definitely think that contributes
to like her anxiety but I do think like
there's something going on with Lady
Gaga no I agree I just I just hope it's
not as big as as as it could be like I
feel it's like something that you know
it's like everyone has struggles you
know everyone deals with stuff everyone
has sadness darkness everyone cries
themselves to sleep at some point except
for this event at some point everybody
except for this event Obama no ELISA I
prom cries herself to sleep because like
she thinks of the olden dog festival no
and she has like things no but she says
there's something that keeps her up at
night well that's said by someone who's
associate and that's what all the women
were like what everybody's kept up at
night of course I use like where do I
begin
yeah me too like literally I was I've
been I've actually like it's been take
me a while to fall asleep recently
because I'm worse I've been having so
much in my mind and I was like thinking
about a lot of things that were just
like stressing me out and then my mind
trailed off to room the movie and it
does every day and I was honestly like
happy be happier being happy having to
think about room yet my own trials and
tribulations well I feel like I'd go
through phases of things that keep me up
and I like now things that keep me up at
night it's like all right people are
onto me and my tour like they're gonna
stop buying tickets that's what keeps me
up now what used to keep me up I don't
know what I was planning my wedding
it's just an absolute misery that's my
mama and it's just it's just so many
like moving pieces even when you have
one piece figured out then it's just
like the next piece drops and it's just
drops the beat drops it's just a lot
it's a big stomachache it is but at the
end of the day that's all like you know
stuff that can be handled as good
problems to have
exactly but yeah I don't know what else
is keeping me up
Stephanie Gabrielle Bonita is that Lisa
Vanderpump definitely cries over finding
Max's parents right and she definitely
cries she was probably House issues
issues like I used to feel like Olivia
culpo had no issues and then I watched
model squad and like now I see what
keeps her up at night yeah and very fair
you know it's so true like there are
people that you see and you're like oh
there's you have the great life like
even like Kristin Cavallari I would be
like she has the perfect life I watched
her I loved Cavallari and she's got
problems just buzz me to her totally and
like he's not super supportive like
right that's a normal thing yes he James
Decker like you think her lady's perfect
I think she stressed out as hell and
like I don't think her life is perfect
and she doesn't give me that much I used
to think so because she's like very
honest and real like she she doesn't
pretend like there are people who you
think their lives are perfect because
they pretend that it is on social media
but she's not one of those people no but
it's like because she's not pretending
it's like we're seeing everything it's
like wow that's really naughty look at
again Chrissy to like you air everything
you would like put your whole vagine on
Instagram and that's how about it is
right so you're showing us the worst of
it and it's just like a stretch mark
right did you see I'm her article in
vogue she's like I know people think I'm
gonna wing and like if I was someone
else and I saw me I would think I was
annoying too
that makes me like appreciate her a
little bit because also it's like
there's nothing she could people made
her and like she'd do anything wrong
like BuzzFeed ruined her no it's vogue
doing a league tail is ruined is she the
last person on the Internet okay it's
the way people like Revere her for doing
nothing that makes me hate being normal
right and be right so being a model who
like knows how to eat chicken wings like
are we supposed to be impressed
right like that and it's not her problem
that she knows how to eat chicken wings
right it's like scraps for being normal
but like everyone else applauding her
for doing like rudimentary there that I
do every day is annoying that's exactly
what it and it's not her fault
no it's not her fault it's BuzzFeed's
fault agreed it's Arianna Huffington's
salt
agreed to Anna Wintour's fault and you
know
like I feel like we haven't been so kind
to her on the show before and I'm
turning a new to actually we need to
fight for her behalf on for everyone to
stop being so respectful I'm gonna see
the Vogue article I'm gonna read it I
feel like that's hentai I didn't read it
at all just saw the headline okay so
when I saw it on Facebook someone
clicked the link and so it was a Vogue
post and the Vogue posted the story and
it was like our time with Christie taken
so I knew Christie can interview and
then also the captain said is Chrissy
Teigen the last tolerable person on the
Internet and then I was like oh it's
your fault
yo Anna Wintour grace there are plenty
of tolerable people on the internet
hello hello welcome to the morning Tosa
Melania morning shall we go live Monday
to Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
Facebook and YouTube and we're also
available as a podcast on Spotify iTunes
stitcher and now Google podcasts and if
you're looking for a more
community-oriented post host experience
head over to the morning toasters
Facebook group maybe you'll make some
friends
you know actually I've decided to turn a
new leaf me too
Wow that's always fun it is cuz it's
hard to change our minds and our hearts
about stuff like that we feel so
strongly about and that we've been like
and it's just hard to like go through
life fighting like your natural instinct
to perceive someone as something do you
know II mean like I will I don't think I
ever could go through life perceiving
Frankie Grande's anything other than the
thirst monster general well that's a
great segue into our next story and I'm
gonna let you take the lead on all of
your thoughts ariana grande quit social
media after a very sad Pete Davidson
split ariana grande is bidding social
media adieu in the wake of her breakup
with Pete Davidson quote okay today was
me special and I'm so grateful I was
able to be there grande wrote in a since
deleted Instagram story via people
referring to Tuesday's taping of NBC's a
very wicked Halloween time to say bye
bye again to the internet just a little
bit it's hard not to bump news and stuff
that I'm trying not to see right now
it's very sad and we're all trying very
hard to keep going love you and thank
you for being here always Grande added
the only thing is weird like why did you
delete it because like if you're
officially announcing your break so like
it's her deleting it saying she's not
breaking any more chiona mean breaking
from the internet know her oh she
deleted the curt announcement said she's
taking a break from the internet but
then she deleted the announcement so is
the break also deleted but maybe it was
deleted because like that's the
beginning of the brain right and it's
like no people screenshot at the second
thought so it's like now you guys know
and now
I'm great ben said he's really grateful
that she followed him before her break
because I believe if she did it like she
never would have right and it's like now
there there are a lot of people out
there who just follow everyone that
ariana grande follows and they'll
probably do that even more so now trying
to get like a hit of her while she's
gone total and though and the wind on
Ben's page I like just I really am
feeling for her these days I feel like
she's universally supported do you know
any means yes like there's no sides like
there's Taylor versus Kent there's no
Ariana versus anyone know she is
universally supported but it's like even
that's not enough because the thing the
things that are like weighing on her
support can't even help I just feel so
bad for her me too she's Bethenny
Frankel who do you think she's gonna
date next because she is like a serial
dater and that's like not a bad thing so
I feel that's gonna get into a
relationship like in the next segment or
two I feel like she definitely has a
type that she needs to stay away from
yeah just like bad boy tattoo bleach
hair messy yeah druggie she needs like
someone with a real like behind his eye
job yeah she needs a business not a Wall
Street guy and now that she's in New
York like maybe she'll find someone like
she should go to like PJ Clark's and
just like meet some of the bit she needs
a big yeah but like a 35 like someone
who has something to wake up for every
day like we think like Colin Jost I
almost called Kanye because I'm always
saying my clothes don't mix it - I love
Michael che and I hate Colin Jost what I
like them both now no I don't like Colin
Jost but we joke that he works one hour
weekly Pete Davidson works two minutes a
week yeah you need someone who has a
reason to get up in the morning right so
you don't you can't be partying every
single night because you have a job that
I say but like maybe if you own a party
on Saturday that's fine
who's someone just to get suggested MGK
which i think is Machine Gun Kelly I
could do that I could see it too but I
don't want to see it now even though I
think Machine Gun Kelly saw it I don't
like really no way I think I've told
this story before can I tell you what my
first experience with Machine Gun Kelly
yes I know it but teleport for the new
vogue listeners okay so when I was an
intern I worked for like a publication
that had like interview series with
celebrities and it was like it was like
legit celebrities most of the time but
every now and then it was like you know
a straggler and then this guy Machine
Gun Kelly kept calling him machine Kelly
like I couldn't I no idea who he was it
was like maybe four or five years ago
and they were like all the seats are
sold out I'm like
he there like he is his cult following
like from the internet I'm like okay no
one cares about literally literally so I
he he he comes he's like a rapper he's
just like looks very odd but like into
it's very niche emo the people that show
up like literally lines out the door
piercings tattoo different color hair
she's had mohawk leather basketball a
gag like the most intense looking crowd
and I was like what and it was mostly
girls I was like this is so weird and
then he comes out and they go wild and
he is like living for it like it's just
a good interview was supposed to be like
Question and Answer like within it with
the moderator like he ripped his shirt
off was screaming's like I'm gonna show
you guys my new track like it wasn't
even a performance like it was and the
girls Jackie like old women with spiked
purple hair screaming at the top of
their lungs Wow and then I was like who
is this guy and then it came in but
that's like a couple years later with
the song with Camila Baio which really
put him on the map and that song is
amazing I think it's literally one of
those songs
[Music]
my mind it finally knew the bad things
like I can't explain it
I have this I also was singing something
else about ariana grande and I don't
want to think it because I don't really
believe Hollywood works this way
completely other than like Nick and
Priyanka but like if you think about the
timeline of her and Pete like they were
the most pop in Turin her album came out
and now that has all died down and they
broke up and like from that from like if
an alien came down to earth and said
good morning Millennials and then I
completely nonpartisan right your party
perspective aliens we have another
planet they they would look at the
situation and say this was a fake
relationship that was used to sell
albums and promote the new season in SNL
yep like I don't believe that that's
true but it's a certain for both of them
is very interesting it just looks a
certain way I wonder if he's gonna keep
his bleached blond hair cuz I was like
totally her thing like she made him be
he looks she made him look horrible and
honestly like let's think about the
CAHSEE David of it all like how she just
must be relieved I mean it's a classic
case of justice being served right on
behalf of a good girl who did nothing
wrong because also what people don't
talk about cuz it's like not it doesn't
sit well but like there was overlap
between of course she was a - kazzie
Ariana but it's like when there's a love
story and there's engagement we're not
gonna talk about the overlap but there
was overlap so like homegirl was out
here being normal in a relationship with
a normal guy for a normal timeline for
like two years and they're like of a
certain age I'm sure she was like maybe
I'm gonna age under there your age yeah
maybe like then getting engaged after
dating for two years and like really
coming up together like wasn't the
craziest thing and they look really
we're in love like their tattoos
everything and he bounces and gets
engaged to home girl in two months and
she's like [ __ ] I been waitin around
for two years like but now justice being
served and I also feel like and it was
great for Cassie's curry like it really
like kind of filtered her and like every
like no one has anything bad to say
about her she's the wrong ones like the
Michelle what's tom brady's we have a
friend michelle monaghan
Bridget Monahan Bridget Monahan from and
she loves this not Michelle no she's
also in Blue Bloods and she is was like
the wronged woman of Tom Brady but no no
it's not the same because
Ariana and Pete broke up so it's like
cause he's like look you left me a happy
relationship just to be miserable and be
a joke now but like it's really sad for
Bridget Monahan because Gisele is
Giselle and Tom Ahern and Tom Brady have
a happy life with a million kids and
[ __ ] Bridget Monaghan's kid lives
with Tom Brady and Gisele okay so Sam on
the lips a kiss still on the lips yeah
no but it would be like if Tommy's
Giselle broke up like how Bridget
Monaghan would feel it would be like how
Jennifer Aniston felt when Angelina
Jolie and Brad Pitt different because
Angelina and Brad had a 10-year marriage
Gisele and Tom Brady even if they broke
up had a 10-year marriage with kids yeah
Angelina and Brad have kids like this
was a joke this relationship was a
two-month farce true it was a
transaction like Cassie wins yeah and
now she's like a total like babe like
who wants to date Cassie like she's well
learning she's a rising star she comes
from a good family like John Mayer's
following her right like who should she
date Matt Harvey we never found a woman
for Matt Harvey no because we don't know
him and that's a problem like because
when we were like talking about it with
someone they were like they were telling
us stuff about him oh we're doing yeah
there's a reason I like that I just feel
like he like likes the rotation yeah
he's not looking for a relationship like
we are for him do you know what a year
ago today was no I haven't checked my
time hub yet service is selling and
selling good service doo-doo-doo-doo did
it do do that video went viral and we
remade it I'll post it on the morning
shows Instagram we've remade it came up
in my time hub we remade it oh my god
that's so cool of us you don't remember
no maybe it literally just a few more
dimensions contagious no only my time my
god wait maybe you made it oh my god
service no selling and selling up was on
them I want to talk like a full body
shot yeah no I can't believe they used
to walk around like just the way that I
was do you don't I mean like with my big
chin my bad eyeliner and like terrible
curly hair oh yeah you don't really wear
your eyeliner anymore I only wear it
like now like for like events and one
night I'm interested there's no need to
be wearing full eyeliner every day
especially like the camera so far you
can't even see me I feel that and I like
your natural look let me to know what
you're rocking right now it's easier to
rock a natural look when you don't have
three chen's I'm not gonna lie very fair
and now with the Botox it's like how
could I know that perfect our head yeah
you
it looks good thank you are you ready
for the next story that I decided to
talk about because we were watching this
per mile video and honestly like this is
just free press for oh yeah for a new
show called nightly pop which is coming
to e and it because it's not safe for
daytime Morgan Stewart Nina Parker and
Hunter March tackle Hollywood's hottest
headlines and gossip after hours
it's called nightly pop on e I don't
know when it starts it's like daily pop
nightly pub right we watch a pv for it
and we also made you watch daily pop
last week because now I catch a few
episodes here and there if there's like
no toast or I'm just like really [ __ ]
bored and I thoroughly enjoy it
no it's premium as hell and I like the
idea of a nightly pop I'm just curious
why they don't have Justin in it because
he is the greatest I mean I wonder if
Morgan's gonna stay on a daily pop and
if she is doing morning and night like
Wow good for her she started like a rich
kid not working if she's like working
very hard and like she's the host of
nightly pop so like this is a promotion
for her it's like her show and it's like
she's doing well she's so funny and he's
serving Justin are so funny and it's
like the other girl I almost feel she
has to like really be them in order yes
she I'm like she reads off the
teleprompter like she tells she keeps
the structure of the show going so she's
kind of like the principal and they're
like the wiley [ __ ] is Wilin out so I
kind of feel bad for her but then she's
also the main host I'm sure she gets
paid more than them so I don't feel so
bad yeah um but I just don't know I
don't know Nina Parker's but she looks
familiar and she looked really funny in
the promo when she was saying that boy
like looks useless I'm not gonna lie
what's his name hunter March I don't
know him he doesn't look familiar and
honestly like how did he get that job
right and like when was the casting for
this because and why weren't we
considered right exactly
but anyways I'm like I'm happy for
Morgan Stewart me too you know what
morning show host support other morning
show host and I really support
Morgenstern I really support I think
she's like the real deal and she's so
funny and like not boring like you don't
have like in order to be a host like you
don't have to be boring like she's so
this is very controversial but like it's
really hard to be like pretty skinny and
blonde and also have like your
personality match how beautiful you are
how do I need obviously it's easy for us
but like no because when you grow up
maybe she like grew up less cute and
like I said work on her she said she was
chubby when she was growing up and I
think she had like a big nose that she
fixed and that could forced her to be
just like more personable but it's like
when if you just saw her you would think
she was like boring just cuz she's still
beautiful and skinny and like has great
she really has it all like great rich
child right right she doesn't even like
have to work married
I like I love her yeah and she's only
been like nice and supportive of me and
the toast and everything she's looks so
nice
totally because it's like daily pop is
really the probably the closest thing to
competition that we have yes it's the
only thing out there that's even
remotely good and close to what we do
but they're on it knew and we're on a
1030 so you can watch both and I watch
it sometimes after our show and we don't
even talk about the same stories which
is so funny because we like do this
exact same thing it's funny that's
because we're like a little bit more of
a business show right we're a little bit
more well-rounded right and they like
talk about interviews that like we're on
a news like like a city guys yeah I need
NBC after all and Jackie is Ronnie
should do that you know cuz we promote
after doe Riverdale's on tonight I'm not
watching life I'm not either because
we're gonna gather right and I probably
maybe I'll watch on the plane to
Cleveland tomorrow right but there's now
like no pressure for me and I'm excited
not to watch live so I can actually
enjoy it so last night like 8:45 I
thought it was Wednesday I'm like oh my
god I missed Riverdale and I don't even
know how to watch it like afterwards
it's like the hardest show to find well
now with YouTube TV I can record it I
don't get it live but it comes I don't
know when it comes up but I think it's
just the next morning so that's perfect
that's great for my schedule know the
next morning look but then we can't talk
about on the show but you're not here
every week will be different maybe some
weeks I'll come watch by you will see TV
will be about to say you read to read
something from the comment oh that
hunter March is an awesome is TV person
and he does stuff with Lauren Elizabeth
okay I love Lauren Elizabeth I don't
understand what awesomenesstv is but I
know one time they stole my tweet and
pretended it was theirs and then I
literally four splits for like ten years
ago I replied to them like are you guys
[ __ ] kid I mean like I literally
wrote this oh you know what it was don't
let anyone tell you you have too many
pairs of black leggings something like
that it was like something basic and
layman like I totally wrote it and they
like literally stole it verbatim and
like made it their own tweet I respond
I'm like literally are you kidding and
they deleted I'm like you're like a
[ __ ] media company yeah but then they
made to otherwise a lot before and like
I forgave them right they made tell the
boys I love a person right now they're
here yeah like I'm I just don't
understand what they do I know they give
like influencers who have absolutely no
influence our audience like they give
them money to make fake shows right very
very like fake stuff right and some real
stuff right people are was like I heard
it's really awesome new people I get my
TV show and it's like an awesome to show
like nobody watches like that's not the
same thing but then they make hats all
the boys love Lauren it's like so are
you real or not like decide right I
don't know next story now getting into a
little bit of health and wellness or not
but the CDC confirms sixty-two cases of
a polio like illness mostly affecting
kids oh sure guys we just turned the
clock back to 1920 FDR is president Jews
Boulevard no I don't know but it wasn't
me it wasn't me either
and he's not here so maybe Theo left was
the president the last time he was the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention has confirmed 62 cases of the
rare polio like neurological condition
acute flaccid my Letus also known as afm
so far this year in the u.s. more than
90% of the cases involve children 18 are
younger with an average of just four
years old cases have been confirmed in
22 states officials said they're looking
at additional 65 possible cases of AFM
so it's like similar to polio and it
affects the nervous system specifically
the area of spinal cord called grey
matter it causes the muscles and
reflexes in the body to become weak or
even paralyzed cases of AFM are
characterized by a sudden onset of
armor-like weakness and a loss of muscle
tone and reflexes damn Africa this is
giving me ebola vibes like is it
contagious I don't I mean not it doesn't
seem contagious cuz it's all very spread
out polio contagious no no looks like
you would be in the tube right thank you
everybody
so many illnesses it's just FTR and
isn't it weird that every time I think
of polio I for some reason think of
Jenny McCarthy cuz it vaccine because
she advocates against vaccines anything
one of the vaccines that she advocates
against is the one for polio because I
think she thinks it's connected to some
of her son's behavioral issues and I'm
just looking out here for people who
don't promote vaccines like it's a super
controversial thing and I feel like on
controversial things like I don't take
sides like I stay out of it but like for
vaccines it's like no your kid can't
play with my kid if your kid like I drew
straws today I'm not with without Shaw I
mean like it's not going down properly I
threw up in my mouth before so it was so
easy it was so crazy I was like leading
down to at my microphone and I guess I
burped at the same time because things
didn't go down well without a straw and
it was throw-up
oh my god scary times you know what you
know how long did it cheering around for
do you think your brother's bad my
breath is always bad at this time of day
no that's true there's no good because
they haven't eaten yet no but like Theo
is not allowed to hang out with any dogs
that aren't vaccinated just cuz that
kennel coughing there's things that go
around like imagine a real child look if
your child it's like coming over to my
house with your polio like get the [ __ ]
out yeah I wonder if these cases are
children who were vaccinated or not
right I mean to
maybe Jenny McCarthy should talk about
that on her show yeah please make sure
you look out for your little ones your
little one you're late so was your
little children that's so sad
little children a great toast movie of
the week the worst one yet
oh wait did we say the new one no we
haven't even discussed it
okay still that's good we're off yeah
give us time to catch up like sorry it's
really hard like it was like the show is
just like never ending do you know I
mean right we could really take the show
till three o'clock it's 11:11 you should
do that like one oh my god we should do
with the Guinness world record for like
longest morning show let's figure it out
let's see what I get like snacks I would
have to wear pajamas great oh but Katy
Perry did that 24 hour livestream that
was like incredibly sad no we should
totally do that jacket okay well look
into it okay also solve an 11 Mukesh
could you could you back that you back
meet you back at your ankles your bag
Gucci Bangu du Bangu du Bangu du Bangu
du Bangu bag Hermes croc Hermes crap
okay I'm a scribe hear me Scott get
everybody's oh thank you Elise for your
comment you two are so uninformed grow
the [ __ ] up I'm out here doing my job
and you're leaving comments and I'm the
one who needs to grow the [ __ ] up I
think you should literally grab a spoon
and eat my ass and then literally go
back to the cabinet you've crawled out
of next story can just legalize
recreational pot here's what you need to
know people in Canada are cheering and
during long lines and honking their car
horns in support in support as the
country's first Mary J dispensaries
open their doors Wednesday I heard so
it's a countrywide that a while because
here at state by sea we're like I feel
like it's really like it well in Canada
I don't have to be Provence but for
balls
it's Provo's by Provence 12 adults and
it's really like a big deal to see how
this is gonna affect like an entire
country no I know and this personally
hits home because I'm dealing with some
some issues in my apartment building
right now in their personal life I was
catching a bunch of flak and I just I
would like to I'd like to restate the
whole thing because I think I got ahead
of myself so me and Ben moved and
there's only three departments on our
hallway and we're one of them and I do
know that another apartment on my floor
is used as an office for an architecture
firm so it's like they're only there for
like eight hours a day like that there's
and they're not certainly not smoking
and every time I get off the elevator
and either smells like weed or
cigarettes and the cigarettes bothering
me so much more cos like what I live in
a holiday and like the whole bite smells
like a motel like it really does and
it's disgust oh you like the Holiday Inn
I actually do nice yeah Howard Johnson
motel 6 like really disgusting and
sometimes it's weed sometimes it's
cigarettes and to me like there's no
difference and I'm not a loser I'm not a
narc like I don't care if you're smoking
pot in your apartment but like also it's
2018 like there's 1 million ways to
smoke pot without a smell like kids do
it every day with they're like little
babes like you could do it too
and the smell has gotten so bad they're
like I didn't narc because they didn't
call the police or anything but I told
my building I'm like yo this is annoying
like I pay a lot and people are like
well people are calling me a loser for
like not being cool with smoking weed
and I don't care like I'm not a loser
like smoke weed all you want all I'm
saying is like the smell is
inconsiderate and there's so many ways
to do it like without getting smelly in
the hallway do it in the bathroom like
[ __ ] stick your head out the window
or do with a brownie like there's a
million ways to die in the way I was
gonna say that also no and also if my
pop my pretty much my life policy is
like you can do whatever the hell you
want as long as it doesn't affect me but
it's infecting you and it's affecting my
hallway and now it's starting to seek
under my door and I'm starting to smell
it in my bedroom and like you have a son
a young son and like his mind isn't
fully formed yet and I have a very
expensive molten Brown linen spray that
like I save just for when company comes
over and I had to use it in the hallway
like 5 spritz and like that's expensive
and that's my money now I'm personally
like at a loss and that's where I get
upset yeah well and and and the building
is starting to take care of it not as
fast as I would like but it's like this
once I have company over they're gonna
get off of Highway and think I live in
like a trash bin it's disgusting and
they say that's not what to wear
anything from just like put a towel I'm
gonna leave a note
seriously and I know that I think that
it's like basic it is a it's like a rich
kid whose parents have her home the
other night when you left bed right we
smelled your cigarettes and I'm gonna
come in that night and slit your throat
if you don't stop for sure anyways
Canadian tenants are gonna have an even
bigger problem this girl was like you're
so mean like you don't know he might
need them weed for medical purposes like
why what he pays rent like that's his
like his valuable mic wise hair I'm more
valuable than mine [ __ ] I pay rent also
okay every argument someone was making I
didn't to open up on my damn since are
fighting with people but like I was
writing every single one do and once you
start
putting up and said I go the people
you've lost your mind every time I don't
why the [ __ ] am I talking to this [ __ ]
no just go respond to all the people who
have the most nice things right you
totally but there are so many more
positive messages a negative ones so
then people realize oh she only
responded by sender and let it get more
negative hey [ __ ] yeah hey [ __ ] uh who
can buy Mary Jane can they you ask yeah
adults of at least 18 years old will be
allowed to carry in an 18 year old
Clanton adult would continue carry and
share up to 30 grams of legal Mary J in
public thirty grams
they will also be allowed to cultivate
up to four plants in their households
and make products such as edibles for
personal use so this is like laissez
faire like really whatever goes it
sounds like bit like more like laid back
than Colorado first shot where can i buy
it the supply of recreational Mary J I
mean cable oh sorry marijuana whatever
marijuana town I was just gonna say that
what are marijuana tap no idea okay
could be limited up and you know what
your neighbor could take marijuana
tablets if they do exist
Chucky literally I don't know anyone who
still smokes pot like from pot you don't
mean yeah like it's 2018 like brownie
Jul bake whatever yeah edibles tablet
tablet just like this one the supply of
recreational many Mary Jake could be
limited at least early on in some stores
it will not be sold in the same location
as alcohol or tobacco consumers are
expected to purchase the drug from
retailers regulated by provinces and
territories or from federally licensed
producers when those options are
available are not available can you
travel in and out of Canada with weed no
okay so every time I talk about this
it's a controversial because people are
very sensitive to it and what I'm about
to say I'm just like to say I'm not
applying this to people who medically
need marijuana like for glaucoma or cure
can't chemotherapy like this I'm neck
pain I'm not talking to you like you
need it and get it however you want but
like this just seems like a little too
relaxed and I definitely like I'm open
to the idea of marijuana legalization
but like unless we not forget it's like
a hallucinogenic drug and I don't know
this just seems like to relax do you
know I think it'll be really interesting
to like see how this plays out and it'll
probably take like years before we'll
get like any sort of understanding on
how its effects the country right but
I'm glad it's happening to Canada any
time but like see in Denver like there's
definitely some positives like the
economy it's created like so many jobs
so many businesses people owning their
own small businesses like and I'm here
for that
that show on CNBC exactly that's how I
learned everything calls I don't know
it's about green money something it's a
it's like a documentary about the
cannabis industry and like how it's
changed certain communities and Denver
it's really interesting how like it
really has economize like that this
whole thing and I think that's great
makes money for the government money for
everyone but like there's also sides of
it that is like not good you know no
furniture cannot allow to talk about
that like it's drugs like I crazy
no it's trucks and people like say it's
not addictive but like I know plenty of
people who are addicted to pot and can't
go one day without smoking pot and it
has affected their life in a negative
way ya know like that's just effectively
it's all around like it's definitely
changed people's lives in a good way
mm-hmm but also in a bad way like Pete
Davidson said he has Crohn's no he has
um something and he's like I literally
couldn't eat and then he smokes pot cuz
like he wouldn't even go taste that he
I'm not talking about him you know
friend in knowledge people who need it
man got to go into class or exempt from
this conversation because I agree with
you you need it and you'll be able to
get it in my perfect world because I
talk about medicine but you can also
abuse medicine right like it's like
pills for sure also interesting previous
pot charges authorities will soon
announce plans to pardon Canadians who
have been convicted with possession of
30 grams or less of marijuana like the
grandfathering I'm in know they'll anti
right yeah yes no people the house three
times in Canada are saying it's really
not as relaxed as article making it seem
like you can't smoke near schools if you
smoke in your car there's a crit like a
penalty for that so it's not as relaxed
well I'm sure it's like alcohol it's
legal but there are rules and
regulations around it like you know you
can't drive with it I'm anyway it's not
a hallucinogenic drug oh sorry I didn't
mean that I just meant like it gets you
[ __ ] up yeah it's like alcohol like
it's not nothin and at the same time
it's like okay so you can buy alcohol
right but then there's are there are
laws around alcohol like you can't drink
and drive
I'm sure there'll be laws around pot
like what can you smoke and drive a lot
of people like a lot of people do smoke
that's like not even a thing it's like I
could drive what it's like not even it's
like I didn't drink I just smoked I'll
Drive right and it's not like look down
on I will not gonna car with somebody
smokes I don't know because I don't
smoke and I don't drive right we're
exempt from this conversation um ya know
it'll be interesting I wonder how it's
gonna be taxed like because tobacco
which is like such a commodities such a
thriving industry is taxed like
at the highest level and it makes so
much money for the government even
though they also try and get people to
stop smoking right so I wonder this will
probably like make a lot of money for
the government and for the people you
know I just think it's like so weird
what you people choose so I get behind
and then like not get behind I mean no I
know but I mean I'm here for the
experimentation in Canada I mean I were
to see all subs realize this is my
mindset like I don't care what anyone
does if what weed is legal and people
want to do it great like honestly the
reason why I never talk about politics
it's just like I can't be bothered like
with other people's issues like it's
just I have too much going on you know
it's the same with this great legalize
it if you want to do it do it if you
don't don't like I'm not ever gonna go
on a rant complaining about weed being
legal or being illegal I just don't care
you know right I'm open to the
hostilities I'm too self-involved to
give a [ __ ] about issues that don't
apply to me like the legalization of
marijuana right and I just I look
forward to seeing how it really affects
a whole country as opposed to just a
state of people who like it you know
it'll be cool yeah it's definitely it's
a big deal and but it'll be a tourist
like a tractor we're oh my god
Montreal's already like a pop in city
cuz they've like casinos and like it's
like now people go to Denver more than
just oh right like it's just Justin
Trudeau casinos pot oh my god it's gonna
lit weed what's like the what's the cool
word I mean I'm personally call it Mary
Jay I call it smoke pot yeah I think I
say Paul it because there's pot weed MJ
marijuana mary-jane bud ganja marijuana
tablets um I wonder what else there's
like it's so funny this is like it's
causing such a stir in the comic I mean
I keep reading it because like people
are very controversial a very extreme
about it on both sides which is great
honestly I don't care
me neither ask me how much it affects
thing and you know what alcohol really
is a crazy substance yeah we live in a
society where it's so true regulated and
it's it consumed then people have enjoy
their lives so okay no I guess it's you
know that's a good point cuz like
alcohol technically does the same things
like to your mind like you get [ __ ] up
as weed but like alcohol does have a lot
of long-term negative effects on your
body and I don't think we does well
but like the good wood natural weed not
like synthetic garbage right but also
the the act of smoking doesn't isn't
that bad for your lungs we're going this
avoid if it's tobacco a read I don't
know no yeah I don't know because people
say it's like good it's like there's
weeds not bad for you that's what
everyone says cuz it's a plant right but
like you're still putting the smoke in
your lungs isn't that bad I think so but
if you're eating an edible yeah breaks
it away I'm just confused but and also
like you can drink too much and I get
alcohol poisoning I don't know if you
can Oh Dee ah marijuana I'm like what
that didn't have a video to show you
really oh my god of you know no is it a
real video that was on the worldstar
years ago and it's stuck with me okay so
it's about oh my god
it's okay it's reefer dab dab dab dab
it's um marijuana wax and it's like yeah
it's like way crazier and it's this
video oh my god the video like gives me
PTSD I can never get over it this like a
little kid who like did it for the first
time done a little kid he's like a
college kid and like all his friends
like [ __ ] up going crazy and like he
is not moving like he's arms body he's
just like looking down he's not moving
for like five minutes straight and
they're all like starting to get worried
about him and like they're like giving
him water and everything and he like
literally isn't moving and then he comes
out of it and he starts screaming
freaking out he was like I was literally
paralyzed kind of in my body
it's a craziest video and it scares the
[ __ ] out of me and I'll show what you
later yeah it's called dab I think it's
like the wax look I'm still not an
expert on this but like if I was gonna
have some Mary Jo I think I would go for
a lollipop those like don't work well
there are trucks in New York like food
trucks and they're like weed candy
brownies like tacos but I've heard that
they don't work because you it's not
legal in New York how can they do that I
don't know but then there's also like a
part of the drug that I think it's
called like see it's see something and
it's like they put it in drinks and it
has the effect of marijuana but it's not
like the actual age thing it's not THC I
don't know there's a I'd watch that show
the MSNBC I was like a lot to learn but
also I just don't think that I
it's like pout it's not for me like I'm
a naturally tired laid-back person that
like if I knew it was gonna do drugs it
would need to be one that gives me
energy
no totally I don't need help having an
appetite I don't need help
relaxing or like not doing much or
falling asleep I well these days
actually maybe I should smoke some
dignity to marijuana tablets yeah I'm I
know a guy yeah all right
to some food truck it seems those are
meals they don't work in it so it's the
money Oh cuz they can't it's not legal
in New York so like if there was a truck
driving around like we sell weed it
would get arrested right yeah it no it's
not legal in New York but you can have a
certain amount of gram and not be like
arrested for it if they find it on you
right and not be arrested yeah
interesting yeah that seems reasonable
yeah it's like I feel like it's either
it shouldn't be so illegal that if they
smell it on you like you go to prison
but it shouldn't be so last day that
like if you're 12 and smoking it and if
a cop sees you it's fine like there's
somewhere in the middle right that's
like alcohol you can't be 12 and drink
alcohol yeah but it's a little alcohols
a little too accessible you think so
yeah I feel like before like now that
we're over 21 like we can get it every
which way but like before you're 21 like
you really have to get creative and
really have to go out of your way and
put your light and put yourself at risk
yeah like trying to my alcohol it's
called CBD is what relaxes you the THC
makes you feel high so they'll put CBD
and stuff now and that's not illegal so
that's probably what they do in the weed
truck with the lollipops definitely okay
well we have to leave somewhat soon
because we are going in with Olivia to
try and wedding dresses
which like has been really great for me
loving every minute of it because I
missed Jackie's appointment because I
was working but I was there in spirit
and I was in the chat like answering
every picture but the only appointments
I've been to are my own which are so
stressful and not fun at all and not
magical like they seem like they are on
TV so I'm just excited to like sit and
judge someone else totally and more I'm
really excited for the sitting and if
you whatting salons are very comfortable
like they make everyone like relaxed I
give you Pellegrino and like good
lighting yeah for the most part for the
most part also we're so behind on all TV
because I've been binging 30 rock you've
been binging yes but how sighs when you
get into a TV show like I haven't I
haven't changed my input back to cable
like in a month yeah I haven't watched a
hazard got a Barnes County not Dallas
neither and I just like I'll catch up at
some point and I enjoy watching them all
together anyway and it when it's such a
thin material like I can't break it down
every week breaking down no there
especially the house of Dowell it's like
breaking down week to week is so
unnecessary like we just need chunks
like Beverly I mean New York when so
much was happening every week like that
deserves a 20 minute spot on the toast
I'm like the news was happening with it
and it was just like Dennis in real life
we needed to bury trash that is Orange
County like does not deserve a minute on
this show per episode
agree I'll catch up before the reunion
and the
breakdown the reunion sounds good it's
just so stupid agreed
I'm back tomorrow with Ben we woken from
a guest card this time so you can ask
him all of your question you will please
be sure to ask how about a cell cycle
experience I'm done I will and now I
hope he had a decent time cuz I'm gonna
make him come with me twin of hypotheses
and I think he'll really enjoy I know
that he won't like the seat and that's
all he'll be able to think about cuz
that's like my thing you put that in his
head but I did it okay
but I did tell him I'm like by the way
you have to get the shoes and you have
to clip into the bike because the first
time I ever did souls I go by the right
I was the first person in this family to
do soul cycle Rachel Hayward dragged me
in the eleventh grade and like now it's
a thing and I was the first person to do
it and we didn't know about the shoes
and we just like went on there with
sneakers and like it was impossible so
if you don't know they didn't tell you
but that's it's actually impossible II
like your feet just follow us right hard
we're like how was everyone doing this
we didn't know interesting so I'm like
Ben get the shoes and lock it he wasn't
listening to me well if he's with
someone who knows what they're doing
he'll be fine and they always ask him to
be any classes anyone new gonna help you
I just can't believe Ben is like a man
about town he's in the know he's a
popular Instagram like he works out a
decent amount he goes to the gym and
he's never done SoulCycle in the last
five years that's really weird and like
he's a part of our family and like you
guys do I just think and his friends do
was Erica's best friend goes every
morning like I think he said I'm doing
my first holes like everyone's done one
I've done like five around so long if
you're from New York like you can't
avoid it like someone's doing a charity
ride that you have to go down right it's
crazy
we'll break it down tomorrow we'll break
it down tomorrow excited to see you and
then it's my Bachelorette and oh they
said his insa story is hilarious he
couldn't get his shoe out oh my god made
it I want to see everyone go watch Ben's
Instagram boy with no job because
apparently he couldn't get a shoe out
hold on boy with oh my my fake Instagram
account I gotta log out your fence tie
my fence does change but I've actually
just made a new one really on my fence
not I don't follow anyone but it says no
job followed by Ariana Grande that's
cool okay for me show me out okay hold
on you're watching his story I'm
watching Ben's story by the way I'm
doing something this morning that I'm
not proud of but have been peer
pressured into doing I can't believe how
much like his video in the class I made
he said is it my ass is killing me he's
literally like I storying during the
class my [ __ ] foot is stuck in this
[ __ ] problem solved my shoe is now a
part of the bike and his shoe fell off
they tell you to do that they say
can't get your shoe off - if you can't
get your bite your shoe on clip just
take your shoe oh my god that's so funny
so Jackie Oh problems it says followed
by sorry there's nothing there let's see
what says that girl with no job
do you follow ariana grande from your
insta followed by I'm afraid like we
have we don't need to be live for this
no oh my god what it said no that's so
weird what because she doesn't but it
says when I type in girl with no job
it says followed by The Ellen Show but
Ellen doesn't did you just check I just
checked out at one point she did then
maybe she heard all the [ __ ] we were
saying about her yeah wanting to see
what all the buzz was about know it she
does not follow me Joey Falls 300 people
but like that is so odd that is so odd
okay okay whatever I think we can end
the show well thank you guys so much for
tuning in to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show we're live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time every day on Facebook and YouTube
we're slowly starting to stream only on
YouTube after Thanksgiving so we're
giving you guys two weeks to be adjusted
so make sure to head over to YouTube
subscribe and then if you're not a
watcher but you're more over a month to
be adjusted whatever if you're not a
watcher but more of a listener we're
available as a podcast as well on
Spotify iTunes stitcher and Google
podcasts and pretty much anywhere you
can hear podcasts make sure to subscribe
and leave us five star review thank you
guys so much for being here I'm Claudia
joy girl in the job I'm Jackie I show
Jackie O problems and I'm posting the
most premium come to my Instagram these
days say she follow me moms - isn't it
so premium do you see the picture fee oh
I'm still breathe